And the way search depends on how the index and ranks are represented is through
the outputs. So, the crawl_web procedure outputs two things, an index and a
ranks list. Both of those are represented as dictionaries, the index maps the
keyword to a list of URLs and the ranks map the URL to its ranks score. In the
search module, a procedure like lucky_search depends on getting both of those
things as inputs. So, this is quite a complex dependency, and this is the kind
of thing that makes it much harder to maintain code, it makes it much harder to
understand code, and it makes it much harder to change code. If we decide to
change something about the crawler, well, we've gotta worry about all these
procedures in search that use these outputs. So, our goal is to hide all that
complexity. In general, the way we hide things is to use Abstraction.
Abstraction is about hiding details. Our goal is to find a way to restructure
the code so we don't need to know all those details and that's a form of
Abstraction, Abstraction is all about hiding details. What we want is an
abstract object that the crawler creates that has the properties search needs to
be able to do its work but without search requiring to know the details of how
that's represented. So, our goal is to replace all this with one abstract
object. We'll call that a Web Corpus, and that will be the output of the crawler
and the input to the search. And we'll end up defining this Web Corpus object in
a new module. What this is, is actually a new type, and Python provides a way to
define new types. They're called classes. Before we get into how to create our
own type like the Web Corpus type that we need here, we're going to step back
and learn more about how types work in Python.